je reçois maintenant jacques higelin
pour la sortie de son cd paradis paille
un doublé d'un retour à la scène au
casino de paris dès demain soir et
jusqu'au 18 octobre
après trois ans de silence
discographique le grand jacques alias
crabes où ils nous jouent le retour aux
sources ça sonne comme une ballade que
rythme le musette le violon tzigane et
la percussion africaine
bref son paradis est vraiment d'en faire
jacques higelin bonsoir alors grosse
actu donc paradis payen le cd le casino
de paris
alors avant de passer aux disques et à
la scène
vous avez fait une autocritique vous
aviez dit que au héros de la voltige
votre précédent album j'ai vu quelque
part vous dit qu'il était ratée pourquoi
on peut comme on peut dire ça non moi je
retourne pas en arrière autre question
serait trop long et c'est pas
intéressant et sur scène vous disiez
j'ai trop fait le comédien sur mes
chansons non sur certaines c'est plutôt
sur les disques
ouais c'est ça c'est solide mais oui sur
les dix que j'avais toujours plus
l'impression que j'étais façon je suis
plus à l'aise en scène
ouais donc je trouvais parfois sur
certaines chansons que j'en rajoutais un
peu sur scène ça passe très bien c'est
différent quoi ici on va y venir ici
c'est pas le cas là parce que paradis
payen c'est vraiment on peut dire
minimaliste et ses parent proche
d'ailleurs c'est parce que c'est assez
pur il ya juste des sons un peu de jean
philippe rykiel sondés sont un peu
techno comme ça technoïde très très
simple alors parlez nous un peu de par
exemple l'accordéon désaccordé comme on
vous l'avait quand vous l'avez inventé
cette chanson une première partie qui
était le refrain à paris à pantin et les
couplets à l'île de gorée
j'étais chez mon amie béatrice soûlé
qu'il avait ouvert sa maison pour écrire
et puis le sang venus des images de
finalement mon enfance mon adolescence
j'ai la chance que j'avais vu les
africains de gorée ça fait longtemps que
je me savais retrouver retrouver leurs
racines ça vous
envie de retrouver le rythme de travail
est à pleurer paname je me disais mais
quelles sont mes racines et j'aime
beaucoup les images sont venus de serre
avec une vitesse incroyable je trouvais
ça marrant que ça arrive à l'île de
gorée alors sur paradis panien il ya
votre femme qui chante assise large
ouais et arthur ashe je n'ai pas envie
de chanter avec lui non je ne sais pas
on en a jamais parlé mais on peut
chanter ensemble ouais vous entendez
bien oui très très bien une fois je vais
demander que si quand il est où je lui
en interview comme ça et je dis mais
est-ce que tu t'entends des biens avec
ton père mais me disais je m'entendais
d'autant mieux avec lui qu'il n'était
jamais là ouais ouais vous avez le
sentiment de l'avoir abandonnée un
moment où à un moment j'en veux pas je
suis parti je suis on en a parlé tous
les deux mais j'aime autant parlé avec
lui on en a déjà parlé
alors cette occasion paris demain vous
êtes prêts oui oui j'étais gens prêts à
jouer oui bon d'accord donc jusqu'au 18
heures alors seul sur scène avec guitare
piano accordéon des bandes aussi enfin
des simples pâtes les bacs des samples
c'est rare donc on vous voit tout seul
comme ça en général fait plutôt des
musiciens sur scène
on devrait tous selon par l etat aux
tout à l'heure dans plein d'endroits où
un jury où je chante et je suis le seul
ouais mais sur scène oui c'est différent
parce que ça demande une grande rigueur
présent il n'y a pas de parce qu'il ya
des mamans ça faisait peur les musiciens
puissent pas vous suivre dans vos
délires par exemple ah non non pas du
tout non mais des fois c'est vrai qu'il
ya certains spectacles où les musiciens
tout d'un coup je me retourne ça fait un
quart d'heure est en train de délirer et
c'est pas toujours marrant pour eux non
plus parce qu'ils partent sur un feeling
et puis tout d'un coup il reste vous
êtes allez vous avez fait cent cinquante
mille personnes en trois mois
en quatre mois quand même énorme et
alors quand vous étiez petit xavier 14
ans free des copains qui jouaient dans
des revues pour adultes au casino de
paris vous attendiez en face au
hollywood barre ouais et et votre père
vous disais peut-être qu'un jour ça sera
toi là parce qu'à l'époque c'était dans
les chevaliers ça sera peut-être toile
futur maurice challe à lille avait vu
marie chevalier au casino de paris
il ya une autre personne qui m'a parlé
de ça c'est madame arletty
un jour m'a dit que c'était un
extraordinaire que dès qu'il rentrait
les femmes étaient pas mais il avait un
charisme fou quoi et puis mon père il
répète ça révèle que je sois ou maurice
la règle pas la réincarnation n'est pas
la continuité de maurice chevalier et
charles trenet un mythe au père était
cheminot mais pianiste il ya enfin vous
avez été élevé comme un peu là dedans
ouais ouais vous avez fait à l'âge de
deux très jeunes à l'âge de quoi 14 ans
des radio crochets dans les entractes au
cinéma même avant on jouit nouvelle
orléans une pierre enfin une comédie
musicale sa sévère 15 ans rien avec
sidney bechet
alors avant de votre carrière on la
connaît on va en parler un petit peu
mais il ya une histoire qui me fait
marrer sur vous deviez faire l'algérie
vous deviez aller faire la guerre en
algérie
et puis vous étiez fait réformer parce
que comme fou et si votre copain marco
picot qui vous a dit vas-y quand même en
algérie parce que non non mais attendez
je vais pas je vais pas inventer un amas
je n'ai pas inventé
non non c'était oui je sais pas qui est
de ma version
c'est de mon frère il a fait trois ans
et les temps d'algérie à cette époque là
quand on avait un frère qui faisait
l'algérie le petit frère on le faisait
partir pas tout de suite
donc j'ai rencontré à risque et en
allemagne où il m'avait caser dans la
musique militaire ce qui est quand même
assez peinard dans les transmissions et
dans les transmissions j'étais dans la
musique
grosse caisse et cymbales et l' arrêt ce
qui était hambourg et là on s'est
rencontré et après après un certain laps
de temps un an et demi je sais pas quoi
je suis parti en algérie six mois où
j'ai fait le déménagement de la de
l'armée française qui revenait après les
accords d'evian perruque marco picot
parce que j'avais rencontré à racheter à
epinal paris qui vous a dit va en
algérie quand même pour faire avancer
l'idée de l'indépendance et tout ça
c'est franchement pas vrai sinon les
discussion qu'on avait avec marcos
c'était de rester dans l'armée pour pour
qu'il y ait des civils engagés pas
engagé parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
engagés volontaires mais d appeler qui
puisse faire barrage un peu tous les
dangers quoi mais ça c'était une vision
qui était d'ailleurs du par
communistes à ce moment-là et marco
était communiste vous avez jamais été
communiste vous deux parties dans votre
famille cole était un peu nicole t'es
pas non plus d'un parti propres membres
mais elle était à gauche ouais ouais
trotsky alors bon sympathie quoi mais
nicole c'était plutôt une anarchie et le
plusieurs higelin donc il ya eu celui
d'avant qui s'intéressait donc
nouvelle-orléans enfin tout ça les radio
crochets après il ya eu une main
l'époque disons baba comme on dit
maintenant
enfin de la fin des années 60 la bonne
entre temps il ya eu des tas de choses
entre temps j'ai fait du cinéma et du
théâtre d'abord comme apprenti acteur
chez rené simon prix françois pérain
ouais ah oui c'est vrai j'ai eu un prix
et puis après je suis parti à l'armée
quand je suis revenu j'en avais jamais
fait de film avant dont un avec marie
laforêt saint-tropez ce blues et l'autre
bonnart est pour demain avec henri
crolla qui m'a fait la gueule car oui et
puis après quand je suis revenu j'avais
pu tellement envie d'être acteurs c'est
marrant ça m'avait quittée et à l'armée
j'ai développé j'ai beaucoup joué
la guitare du piano et tout mais je
voulais vraiment être musicien alors
changé de cette époque formidable disons
bien ça il ya eu des théâtres oui c'est
ça la rave à pierre barouh il ya des
années seulement après envie de rien
faire voilà début 70 71 72
vous avez tourné un film a de quoi elle
croit la banlieue et puis là il toute
une période de communautaire vous viviez
avec maxime le forestier non sa femme
non avec sa soeur dans sa maison l'a été
pendant la maison de sa mère on a été un
moment avec catherine et puis tout une
bande de copains qui avait il y avait
aussi des artistes en fête des deux
époques dans votre vie en 73 aguerris
lagrange en 73 vous faites un concert
vous faites un concert en première
partie de cela les familles voilà vous
avez les cheveux longs habillé en blanc
et un accordéon vous fait jeter et le
lendemain c'est vrai que vous avez
acheté un blouson noir dj allemand
demain mais à ce moment là j'ai pris ça
en pleine poire et j'ai dit d'accord
c'est la guerre alors j'y vais ce virage
rock et là je me suis habillé
on va être dans ensuite bon votre
carrière de 75 à 85 tout le monde la
connaît c'est vos grands ça commence et
que d âge 75 alertez les bébés et
champagne pour tout le monde et c est en
4e 25
là aussi problème c'est à dire vous fait
un gros gros barnum à bercy avec albert
koski 100 personnes 100 1000 watts et
dur et mory kante voilà et vous plantez
18 millions enfin ça plante
moi j'ai rien planter ses cosmique a été
ruinée après il a manqué deux spectacles
en même temps on a fait une gigantesque
tournée et qui avait jamais eu autant de
monde en province a eu autant de gens il
y en a eu beaucoup à paris aussi on a
joué quand même d'un concert ouais non
mais c'est pas je dis pas ça pour être
désagréable jeudi sa part des choses
comment il eu des tournants dans votre
ville tournante 73 va après ce concert
de sly family stone ensuite
effectivement quand ils bercy après on a
fait une tournée d'un an qui a été
phénoménal et à la fin de la tournée
j'étais vraiment épuisé j'ai posé mes
affaires je me suis reposé un peu mais à
ce moment là j'avais envie et c'est là
où albert à déposer le bilan mais c'est
un an après je peux pas alors bon vous
êtes vous dit toujours que vous lancez
j'étais ravie de faire cette aventure
avec lui parce qu'elle était très gonflé
avec vous a toujours été depuis le début
et puis très très gonflé vous dit
toujours que vous luttez contre
l'hypocrisie sociale et généralisé alors
qu'on vous dit j'aime pas les curés bon
c'est pas très transgressif de dire
j'aime pas les curés c'est un peu facile
en revanche celui d'élections je trouve
plutôt drôle c'est quand il ya eu au
stade de france le défilé yves saint
laurent avec tous les mannequins sur la
pelouse
vous avez appeler ça un défilé de
puteaux ça c'est vrai que c'est déjà
plus moins consensuel
ouais mais c'est pas une question de
temps sensualité j'aime pas les curés
parce que j'aime pas que là que dieu
sera présentée par une
j'ai vu encore une photo ce matin du
pape entouré des cardinaux l'arrêt dans
une grande sculpture j'sais pas quoi et
puis bon c'est une idée qui me séduit
pas mais les gens qui croient tant mieux
quoi je veux dire j'ai pas le juge après
après vous lors d un débat sur un livre
qu'il s'en fout moi je suis pas fou par
l'église
moi c'est moi même chose qui est d'abord
il faut pas oublier que l'église
catholique est un moment donné a quand
même fait trucider 1,7 certain nombre de
gens et en plus au moment des
colonisations
ils sont venus d'abord avec la croix
après ils sont bien que les paie quoi
bon mais c'est tout mais ça regarde
chacun d'avoir la foire son pendant
je peux avoir la foi en dieu sans avoir
besoin de passer par l'église tout à
fait tout à fait ça veut pas dire tous
les curés ne sont pas bons et ça j'ai
des copains de son curé quoi ça va bien
que pas mal alors il y en a qui prennent
des risques puis quand vous occupez
drôlement bon quant au mannequin je sais
pas pourquoi j'ai sorti un truc pareil
mais c'est la même genre de généralités
quoi ouais c'est comme dire peut-être
tous les chanteurs sont des plus tôt
dites moi sur scène c'était un peu
démago quand même c'est le truc qu'on
pourrait vous reprocher vous fait des
rappels de quatre heures c'est un fait
c'est de la démagogie de la démagogie
sur vous vous vous parler avec le public
vous vous en rajoutez besoin mais même
vous vous dites quand vous des fois vous
écoutez les cassettes de vos concerts
vous dit tu as ta gueule je trouve qu'il
ya des écoutes envolée gueule oui parce
qu'il ya des grandes envolées que je
contrôle pas ouais je me lance et je
pars mais je me suis jamais senti j'ai
jamais eu envie de flatter les gens
comme en scène je pense jamais à ça vous
épancher un peu disons c'est un peu vous
les flatter un peu quand même flatté
enfin vouloir parler je leur parle parce
qu'il m'aime et je les aime
res moment là en tout cas je peux ça
veut pas dire que j'aime tout le temps
tout le monde mais ça veut dire qu'à ce
moment là il peut y avoir une ambiance
fantastique et c'est effectivement pas
quelqu'un qui j jaurès à l'extérieur et
froidement dirais c'est quoi qu'est ce
qu'il en fait là moi je m'entende
je me sens bien avec les gens c'est tout
est abandonnée je leur dit et comme je
passe pas beaucoup il ya la télévision
ni ailleurs je parle directement dans la
vie vous avez vous à voir chez nous
alors pour terminer comme je suis pas un
médiatique je suis pas bien parler aux
gens directement pour terminer une
question pas très bons en 80 même pas ça
à 92 vous avez dit tu mets d'un oui
c'est sûr je vais aller mais revenons
oui c'est l'e3 yanis des piqûres et
aussi d'ailleurs vous êtes habillé comme
un clergyman oui c'est un peu énervant
que c'est que la télé dépréciateur
énervant il n'a pas tellement
oui mais pas tellement ce mariage à la
télé faut qu'un canal qui sont un peu
moins de 100 avec les autres c'est vrai
alors en 92 l'avait dit ça sera la
dernière
pardon et il est un joli regard à 50 on
vous avait dit en 90 ans 50 ans on
commence à descendre comme j'ai 50 ans
c'est pas du tout négatif ce que je vous
dis mais est-ce qu'à 58 vous emmener
tous alors se ferait donc huit ans vous
des cendriers normalement ouais mais
c'est la descente les très belles aussi
bon très intéressant voire non mais vous
avez amené à 58 ans je dois vous faire
un compliment pour finir on savait à mr
extrêmement juvénile ouais non mais
c'est vrai qu'en le regardant la gueule
penserait pas que vous avez 58 ans ah
oui il ya un copain qui a sorti un truc
qui me plaisait bien les diamants on
était jeune et beau maintenant on est
beau on merci alors demain soir donc je
le dis à nos amis téléspectateurs donc
paradis payen voilà un jeu là voilà et
demain soir donc au casino de paris
jusqu'au 18 octobre juste après maurice
chevalier jacques et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux